d'accord donc nous entrons dans la fête séparément en tant
qu'invités vous pouvez les quarts bien gène
parce que les codes étaient un milliardaire
j'éteins la trouvaille vous sautez dans l'
ordinateur je et je vous attrape vous branchez
l'émetteur puis Ethan me donne les
codes que j'utilise ensuite  pour identifier l'
emplacement de Hendricks, d'accord, vous venez de
survoler quelque chose que je pense vraiment
important, la partie de la baie d'ordinateurs où
je saute et je vous attrape ouais, je ne sais pas
pourquoi est-ce si difficile de comprendre pourquoi
c'est une chute de 25 pieds I '  d être plus
inquiet à propos de la chaleur et puis il y a
que quelle chaleur bien c'est comme n'importe quel
ordinateur ne l'est pas si vous éteignez le ventilateur
il va frapper très fort bien sûr
ouais forcer donc je saute dans un four
essentiellement ouais essentiellement mais euh je  Je vais l'
attraper
bon
travail maintenant oui madame ça saute-saute-saute
et je vous attrape maintenant
donc vous êtes sûr de ce costume, n'est-ce pas
Bungie à peu près sûr maintenant que vous êtes assez
court
saut
Oh
saut saut